Експерти Міжнародного агентства з атомної енергії завершили свою першу екскурсію гігантським ядерним об’єктом на Запоріжжі.
За останні тижні окупована Росією ЗАЕС зазнала кількох потенційно катастрофічних збоїв.
МАГАТЕ прагне розмістити там своїх постійних представників, незважаючи на небезпеку ракетних ударів поблизу.
Ми нікуди не йдемо. МАГАТЕ зараз на АЕС і не йде звідти, а збирається залишатися там.
Ми маємо намір забезпечити тривалу присутність там на заводі з кількома моїми експертами.
І, звісно, зараз у моєї команди багато роботи щодо детального аналізу деяких більш технічних аспектів того, що ми бачили.
Тим часом українська сторона розчарована заявами Гроссі.
Адже головною метою українських та міжнародних зусиль є демілітаризація ядерного об'єкту,
а закликів МАГАТЕ до РФ вивести свої війська з території ЗАЕС так і не прозвучало.
Коли нарешті з території Запорізької АЕС вийдуть російські військові,
коли вони заберуть свою зброю, боєприпаси, коли вони припинять обстріли Енергодара
та сусідніх районів і свої провокації, Запорізька станція зможе повернутися до цілком безпечної роботи,
яка й була завжди під контролем України.
І головне, що має відбутися, – це демілітаризація території станції.
Саме це є метою українських і міжнародних зусиль.
І погано, що ми поки не почули відповідних закликів від МАГАТЕ.
Хоча й говорили про це з паном Гроссі на нашій зустрічі в Києві.
Це був ключовий – ключовий! – безпековий пункт наших домовленостей.
Це говорилося чітко: демілітаризація й повний контроль українських атомників.
Українська сторона також оскаржує, що окупанти не пустили незалежних журналістів на територію ЗАЕС -
натомість організували масовку своїх пропагандистів і намагаються перетворити місію МАГАТЕ
на Запорізькій АЕС на безплідну екскурсію по станції.
Схожі застереження в інтерв'ю DW висловив також один з колишніх працівників ЗАЕС Олег Коропець,
який до минулого тижня, коли він востаннє був на зміні, працював інженером на АЕС.
Чоловік не вірить, що місія Міжнародного агентства з атомної енергії зможе вплинути на ситуацію.
І сумнівається, що МАГАТЕ отримала повну картину того, що відбувається на електростанції,
судячи з того, як організовувався візит знімальної групи російського телебачення.
Тобто вони показали на камери, що вони вивозять техніку, що там все нормально.
Тільки телебачення поїхало - вони назад привезли.
Розумієте, вони дуже гарно - вони цього навчилися, у них пропаганда працює відмінно -
вони навчилися показувати картинку.
Ось приїде МАГАТЕ - вони покажуть картинку.
МАГАТЕ поїде - і буде все, як раніше, нічого не зміниться.
Коропець також переживає, що дедалі більше його колег, як і він, залишають свою роботу.
І що ризик ядерної катастрофи зростає не лише через ймовірні обстріли, але й через брак персоналу.
Потрібно щорічні ремонти проводити. А зараз ці ремонти не проводяться. Це атомна станція.
Все повинно бути як годинник, тобто день, година, доба. Ремонт початку - ремонт кінця.
Графік є на кожен день, на кожну зміну. Це повинно бути як годинник.
А зараз годинник поламався. Він то тікає, але він поламався…
У Національному науковому центрі радіаційної медицини вважають, що цей аспект -
захист працівників ЗАЕС і забезпечення їм нормальних умов праці -
теж має бути на порядку денному місії МАГАТЕ.
Вкрай важливо, щоб психологічний тиск на працівників ЗАЕС було послаблено.
Адже вони уже майже шість місяців під дулами російських військ, що аж ніяк не сприяє безпеці.
Тим часом у Європі зростають занепокоєння щодо ризику нової атомної катастрофи на континенті,
наслідки якої можуть бути навіть гіршими за Чорнобиль.
Не дуже доречно порівнювати наслідки Чорнобиля з можливими наслідками аварії на ЗАЕС.
По-перше, це різні типи реакторів. А також різні причини.
У будь-якому випадку ризик аварії на ЗАЕС дуже високий.
Наслідки такої аварії можна буде радше порівняти з Фукусімою, а не Чорнобилем.
Але за найгіршого сценарію наслідки аварії на ЗАЕС можуть бути гіршими, ніж Чорнобиль і Фукусіма разом.
Адже там ішлося про один або два реактори.
У випадку Запоріжжя - це аж шість реакторів і відповідно більші обсяги атомного палива.
Якщо постраждають всі реактори, наслідки будуть катастрофічними для всієї Європи, не лише для України.
Тим часом мешканці Енергодара масово тікають з міста.
Деякі з цих людей провели години, а деякі - дні в очікуванні цього моменту.
Хтось тікав від боїв, хтось - від життя в окупації, а хтось - і від нової ядерної загрози.
Енергодар від нас виходить напряму 40 кілометрів.
Офіційно ми ніби не потрапляємо до радіаційної зони, але неофіційно ми там.
Теж там стріляють. У нас дуже чути постріли. Тому ми зірвалися, зібрали речі та й кажу - їдемо.
У Запоріжжі біженці реєструються, отримують їжу та допомогу.
Автобуси чекають на тих, хто хоче їхати далі.
За останні кілька днів багато хто прибув з Енергодара, який постраждав від обстрілів.
Ми поговорили з кількома людьми, які щойно покинули Енергодар та атомну електростанцію.
Вони говорять про постійні обстріли, вони кажуть, що бояться того,
що може статися з атомною електростанцією, і що вони хочуть поїхати звідти якнайдалі.
Жоден з них не погодився говорити на камеру, побоюючись за родичів, які залишилися на окупованій території.
Ніхто не знає, як довго цей шлях втечі з російської окупації ще буде відкритий.